is it the greatest feeling as a man to
take down a quarterback oh my goodness
what does that feel like when you come
around that corner and you put that move
on that alignment and you turning and he
squared up in that pocket you know you
can't hear anything at this point right
it's like you're in a tunnel
and it's just like that it's quiet yeah
and when you hit him and drop and you
hear that
from him that's the first thing you hear
from him when you open your eyes or you
look up it's like somebody just like
took headphones off of you and the crowd
is there and chill but uh getting them
now i know
and the fans go crazy and your teammates
love you
they don't know what to do oh yeah they
beat you upside the head it
hoping to stir it down so you're done
but sometimes it's second and then you
got another play so you got to bring
yourself back from that you know oh man
do you feel good
like do you do you if you break that guy
like literally break his leg
well listen you can't control that if
you if you hit a guy like like with the
lawrence taylor and um
when you wrapped him like that remember
i think he was just wrapping him like a
ball constrictor because he wanted to
take him down and then when you and you
saw lawrence's reaction when he jumped
up like come help him you don't never
want that feeling on your resume because
that entertisement's career that was it
i mean he never really recovered
that's that's before modern medicine so
you would feel bad doing that to
somebody oh my god did you ever end
someone's career no so have you ever
held back so that you don't you haven't
hold back no so you hit him and you hope
that you don't kill him i know what the
hidden area is but don't you think it's
a crazy sport in a sense because a guy
your size was your speed
yeah but a guy your size with your speed
coming at that velocity and sometimes
quarterbacks are blind on their one side
to see you they go down i mean it is a
tr that's the train wreck they go that's
what i want don't you think in a way
someday football will change and you
will not be allowed to hit the
quarterback that you'll almost be like
two hand touch you're going to be hey
hit the receivers now they built the
autobahn in the middle field where you
been that's what i'm saying do you love
the game oh love it love it and you love
being a commentator you love you you
love the whole thing all of it there's
nothing better than a kid's game